este edificio de la administración de
procrapses solo un ejemplo de la
destrucción que hay no solamente en esta
población sino en las áreas aledañas
esta fue una región que se convirtió en
el frente de batalla entre las fuerzas
rusas que estaban en la provincia de
gersón el frente de batalla estaba menos
de un kilómetro de aquí donde se puede
ver era parte de un canal de un río
donde estaban las posiciones de ambos
ejércitos y Desde allí intercambiaban
tanta artillería que todas estas
poblaciones quedaron totalmente
destruidas nosotros no visitamos en mayo
del año pasado en ese momento aquí
estaban ubicadas unas cuantas tropas
ucranianas y ellos nos contaban como
constantemente caía la artillería detrás
de nosotros Al fondo hay un colegio que
para entonces estaba semidestruido hoy
está totalmente destruido Y esto es un
ejemplo no solamente lo que encontramos
en esta parte de línea de batalla a
menos de 45 kilómetros de aquí está la
ciudad de Nicolás que desde entonces era
totalmente atacada sino que muchos de
esos pueblos alrededor de gersón y que
lindan con el río que hoy son frente de
batalla están en circunstancias como
esta que nos dejan un ejemplo de esa
gran destrucción que ha dejado esta
guerra